Cómo caracterizaría el rol que
históricamente ha jugado Estados Unidos
en medio oriente qué intereses tiene en
esta región
a ver la región es muy importante para
Estados Unidos tanto de su punto de
vista estratégico como su punto de vista
de energía la verdad que la posición de
Estados Unidos Fue Cambiando al
principio con lo que es el
descubrimiento del petróleo Saudita
principiante luego fue de una forma
mucho más activa recordemos que la era
del 70 Estados Unidos es el mediador
entre Egipto y Estados Unidos en lo que
representa el primer pacto de paz entre
el estado hebreo y un país árabe luego
interviene de forma Más directa lo que
las las dos guerras del Golfo intentando
una especie de movimiento de
democratización en la región y yo creo
que a partir de la presidencia de Obama
y la de Trump parece que hay una
continuación en la de biden Estados
Unidos tiene una decisión un poco de
sacar los pies de la región y estamos
viendo Estados Unidos un poco más
timorato en participar en conflictos
claves de la región y otros países otras
potencias ocupando ese lugar a partir de
esto que cuenta usted Estados Unidos es
visto como un interlocutor válido para
los conflictos en la región y en
particular para el Israel palestino
a ver con respecto y digamos que en
muchos conflictos de la región Estados
Unidos ha sido participe porque tenía
intereses en en cuanto el conflicto
Israel palestino es interesante porque
yo creo que el rol de Estados Unidos en
el conflicto palestino siempre ha sido
tratar de buscar un tipo de resolución
recordemos que los parámetros de Clinton
en el año 2000 y también lo que fue la
conferencia de nápolis de alguna manera
mediada por lo que fue el el el último
presidente el único presidente de la
dinastía Bush hijo fue lo más cerca que
estuvieron palestinos e israelíes de
llegar un tipo de acuerdo lo que lo que
pasa es que los palestinos poco a poco
están viendo el rol de Estados Unidos
como que siempre de alguna manera
intentó favorecer a los israelíes pero a
la vez hay que pensar que Estados Unidos
es el único actor o la única potencia
mundial que de alguna manera puede
llevar a los israelíes a hacer algún
tipo de concesiones ahora como afecta el
nuevo gobierno israelí las relaciones
con Estados Unidos
de ahí Tenemos un gran problema porque
la propia composición del actual
gobierno israelí donde de los seis
socios de la coalición cinco son dos
representan al azul ortodoxos religiosos
y otros tres representan a lo nacional
religiosos a los movimientos de las
colonias tu propia naturaleza hace como
que sea una crónica de un conflicto
anunciado con Estados Unidos porque
Estados Unidos va a tratar que Israel
muestre una cara de moderación con los
palestinos pero la propia naturaleza de
la coalición israelí de alguna manera
previa que va a haber un conflicto con
los palestinos creo que Estados Unidos
no tiene muchas como mucha esperanza de
que el actual gobierno israelí va sobre
un acuerdo con los palestinos Pero va a
tratar de moderarlo